how to be a great communicator great
communicators are people who can take
complex big important topics and distill
it down into simple easy to understand
ideas that people can grasp that's the
big difference I get to many
entrepreneurs who come in there write to
me and they say let me tell you my story
and this is pages and pages and pages on
email their story I don't have the time
to read that people don't have the time
to sit down and read all this stuff you
have to be able to quickly tell your
story explain your company through
sentences that are short and that are
easy to understand this is your role as
an entrepreneur you have to be a great
communicator if you want people to come
on board and believe in what you're
doing you know I'm not perfect when I
when I started I was I was terrible I
was the worst at this I had a biotech
software company and was out there
trying to get partnerships and and and
we're thinking about raising money and
we didn't have a lot of success with our
elevator pitch you know we walk in and
people wouldn't get quite what we did
and we had to explain it and we just
thought you know if we had somebody just
to sit down with us for an hour we could
explain everything we really believed
that we had a great idea that it would
help change the world that it was a
great way to make a lot of money for
whoever was involved we really believed
in our product this was just some easy
quick way to make money this was a great
idea and we felt like if somebody could
sit down with us for an hour we can go
through everything and they would
understand and they'd see how they can
make a lot of money see how they could
have a big impact with us the problem is
people won't give you that time not up
front
they won't commit to that what you have
to do is quickly explain to them make
them feel something in a couple of
sentences and then from there they're
going to ask questions and you may still
end up spending the arrow with them but
it's from them being curious and wanting
to learn more and asking questions
instead of you taking an hour to explain
your story
that's a big difference you look at
Martin Luther King let the Equal Rights
Movement
he had a message that you could quickly
and easily understand black people and
white people should have equal rights
easy to understand how do you go about
doing that how you go about impacting
and making change that's complex you
have to change a lot of laws you have to
do something nationwide you got to do
something on an individual state level
there's there was so much that had to
happen to make that change happen and if
he stood up and said this is really
complex guys you know what I need an
hour to sit down and talk to you about
it nobody would listen instead he stood
up with a powerful message that was easy
to understand and from there he could
explain it and people could asking
questions you could drill down but you
have an engaged audience and that's the
power when you are a great communicator
for your business you need to have the
same thing you need to have one sentence
that quickly explains what you do and
makes me feel something makes me curious
makes me want to ask you more question
and I might spend an hour with you but
it starts off because you've given me
something that I am excited by I feel
something and I'm curious to learn more
that's how you be a great communicator
you take these complex big problems and
distill it down into one or two
sentences that people can understand and
it cures to learn more about believe
those are watching and like the video
please give it a thumbs up leave a
comment below and let me know you think
you have a question leave it in the
comment section below and click on my
face to subscribe to the channel and see
more videos like this thank you so much
and I'll see you soon
you